but like i'm really like how do you feel
about quotas
i i think
in
i'm laughing because someone in the
comments said jess i think sorry i say
it a lot but um
for me i would say that in some cert
circumstances that a quota is
necessary okay um
just so for representation purposes okay
um
don't you think it's a little like um
sexist or racist
because because it's like almost saying
that these like like if i'm a woman i
can't get the job myself i need the
government to tell them to do it yeah
like and i i think it actually hurts the
people because then people just start to
think you got there because of a quota
rather than your competence yeah
you make a good point you make a good
point and it's okay if you disagree this
is just how i oh no yeah
okay
it's hard because
yes
a quota would just be like oh i just
hired you because you
we needed to meet a quota and that's all
and they didn't look at your
your um
jobs that you've had before and
everything and your qualifications they
just look like oh you're this we we need
to check this box and check this box
this person does it we'll
train them and so in that in those type
of cases yes it's
it is like
not good it's harmful not harmful but it
does hurt the
the person and it's just like they they
didn't get the job because they were
qualified they got the job because of
something
that they needed a quota that they
wanted and you know it's really hurting
like minority communities and education
because um colleges like that's what
they do but the problem is like it makes
smart kids fail because they're at the
wrong university
so no it's like thomas sowell has a
whole book on like the decline in dogma
of education that's what they're talking
about in there too
and like because like let's say me okay
i i'm i'm i'm decently smart okay i'm
good at school but i'm not smart enough
to get into say um michigan like i think
that was like a pretty smart or let's
say okay yeah and if they let me in i
would leave thinking i was stupid
because i could not compete okay so if i
i got like a 23 24 and you guys have
sats we have a cts oh and we're where i
went to school uh we have the sats and
ac okay so yeah you know where 23 24 is
yeah that doesn't i'm above average yeah
that doesn't make me like like dumb but
like i would feel dumb at the wrong
school
so if they're going off of like what you
look like it almost hurts you later
because you're not qualified yeah and
and they show that because like um
like the kids with the lower ac2 scores
drop out at a higher rate or they switch
their major
hmm even though like they could have
done that fine if they went to like i
went to school right yeah
wow
and so it's almost like and it's funny
because the people that pat themselves
on the back and they're saying i'm
fighting for these people i'm doing a
good job they're hurting them
yeah wow
i never thought about it isn't that
interesting yeah because then you have
yes representation matters but
representation in the i would say in the
right way matters when you
know like you're supposed to when you're
when you go to the areas you're
qualified that will help you
best because if you're if you're in an
area where say
i know nothing about tech but i applied
for like a tech job and they just needed
i heard they just needed a young black
female to be to work there and i got in
there it wouldn't benefit me at all
because i'm not qualified but i'm
qualified for their quota and you would
and you would feel dumb even though even
though you're not because you're at the
wrong place
like have you ever been in a room and
you just feel like oh plenty of time so
i i can't count
so many times
i should not be here right but it's
because it's not because like like i've
been in places where i'm the dumbest one
in the room and it's not like
it's helpful at times but you don't want
to feel like you can't compete at all
yeah you don't want to feel like you
can't
interact with the conversations
it'd be like if the lions the london
lions took me on their team because they
needed a ginger
need a tall ginger all right you would
eff me up
and i wouldn't improve at all because i
would just get my like get rocked every
day
those girls are killed the guys the
london lions is like a basketball team
yeah wbbo
so they're like one of the top good one
of the best teams in europe right now so
yeah that that makes sense yeah what do
you think okay one more question what do
you think about what he said about
education
um what was your major uh physical
education
like pe yeah oh i didn't know that was
like a major i thought it was just
education um
the school i went to it was separated
and then anything like physical activity
that has to do with the body is now
underneath kinesiology
and so that's why it wasn't just
education it was more
science
a little bit yeah so i don't know if you
had the same experience as me
but i felt like the colleges are very
left and like they very much pushed like
at my school they would push like
like trans stuff like my school was
really known and like they wanted like
it was like known for bringing trans
people in the dorms and it was like very
much like the left and feminist ideology
was in all the classrooms and like
i i felt like it was very much pushed on
us did you feel the same or no no
because the school i went to was a
christian school so
we had the
first year i was there there was a
teacher that
i think they were trans and it like blew
up that
they didn't you were the opposite yeah
the complete opposite and it blew up to
where um
that person was released or wasn't able
to work there because of that because of
the beliefs that the school had
and then there were some
gay students that came to the school or
students that just didn't believe in
what the school believed in and they
like went at the um
the head people and just told them like
this is wrong you should welcome
everybody
and so yeah it was a complete opposite
do you think a school has a right to
have its beliefs about that stuff
i think if
dang it
if
if a school
it's hard because if if i
if i wasn't who i am and i went to a
school that didn't
technically accept me but that's like
the best school for me and that's where
i think i would excel the most i should
have the right to be able to go to that
school no matter who i am or what i
believe but it's hard when a school is
based on like that's their foundation on
what they believe and they have it like
your school had like feminism and trans
stuff that's like in the classrooms and
taught that's how it was for us and
almost every class or we had to take
bible classes and we had to do an
exegetical i haven't never heard of a
college doing that yes and we had there
was i write the name of it
as is am i allowed to say it
if you want that's mine azusa pacific
university i don't have never heard of
it yeah um it's in azusa california but
um
in california yeah
yeah and so um we had to do in every
class it was
a paper where what we were learning how
do we connect it to scripture how we use
it with that so we had that in the
classes and it was it was difficult for
students who either were catholic or
atheist or
just a different religion or didn't
believe in anything
and
they were like well why do we have to do
this i don't believe in it and
it's hard because that school was based
on that but also like they had great
programs that different people came
there for and it's like why should i be
denied access to a great program that i
think i will excel at because i don't
believe the same thing i just feel like
if if the the school i feel like the
school has a right to market to who they
want to market to and that just wasn't
who they were marketing yeah just like
my school like i didn't try to make them
not trans rights i just i just minded my
business yeah exactly but i said would
they not let you in if you were gay or
was it just like if you were publicly
like
i don't i don't know if they didn't let
people i know they they let them in
um
it was just it's hard when
yeah
it you have to go to chapel three times
a week and you had to go to chapel one
three times a week and if we missed 10
or more chapels throughout the semester
we had to we
either got fined or had to like write a
paper or something we had very different
colleges yeah